こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
本日はこちら、湘南の方にちょっと旅行チックな感じで遊びに来ているんですけども、
今回こちらの湘南にはじゃらんnetで予約してちょっと旅行に来ております。
僕ちょっとこの湘南で旅行している間に１つどうしてもやりたいことがありまして、
やはり人類の夢である、空を飛ぶことにちょっと挑戦してみたいと思ってまして
この湘南の海の近くに、実際に空を飛ぶことができる場所があると言うことなので、
ちょっと実際にそちらの方に行ってみようと思います。
では！行ってきまーす！
うわぁぁあーーー　　　　　　　　　　　　うーわ
やばい！これは！やばい！
よーし
ちょっとここで、
着陸だぁ…怖いよ
うぉ
あ！あ！あははっはっ、、うぁーーーー
うわーすごい！
うわすっごかった
いやー　　すごい
いや結構怖いもんですよ。怖いですけど、景色はすごい良かったです。
いやーよかったよかったー。
はい！というわけで無事体験が終わって旅館の方に来ましたー。
今回の旅はですねー、じゃらんnet、皆さんご存知の通りじゃらんnetで予約して、
旅、してきたんですけども、
じつはですね、じゃらんnetで予約することによって、
僕も毎日、ポイントためてるんですけども、ポンタカード、知ってますよね、
そのpontaカードにですね、じゃらんnetで予約して旅をすると
ポイントがたまるようになりました！
いやーもうこれ僕4年前からずっと使ってるpontaカードなんですけど
いやーいつも貯めてるポンタポイント、旅するだけでたまるようになって、すごい、僕も今後、活用してみよっかなと思っております。
ハイ今、僕が食べてるこちらの肉まん、唐揚げ、おにぎりなども、じゃらんnetとかで予約してたまったポイントを使って、かうことができます。
このコンビニで買ったことによってさらにポンタポイントもたまるので、ポンタポイントで買ったものに、ポンタポイントがつくので、すごい有効的な活用の仕方ができます。
ポイントでポイントをためるみたいな感覚です
今回コンビニでご飯買ったんですけども、こういう使い方以外にもポンタwebを使えば様々な使い方があります。
あの、僕さっきポンタwebで実際に何ポイントあるか確認したんですけども、
1300point貯まってました。かなりpoint貯まってます。僕は。
なんで、こう、たくさんたまったポイントも、ポンタwebでいろんな使い方ができます。
というわけで皆さんぜひ、ポンタweb。ポイントすぐ貯まるんで、ポンタwebをうまいこと利用して、いろんなことに使ってみて下さい。
じゃぁな！